ráfagas de cohetes desde gaza hacia los
territorios israelíes fue la primera
respuesta a los bombardeos de estos días
en los que fueron asesinados tres
líderes de la hija de islámica y sus
familias pero sin éxito Ya que el
sistema de defensa aérea consiguió
neutralizar a todas las bombas no
obstante ante la viv Israel se siente la
tensión
las sirenas antiaéreas despertaron el
temor de los ciudadanos Pese a que no
pasó nada
vi a la gente correr al baño que era
como el espacio protegido todos nos
acurrucamos allí vemos dos
intercepciones sobre nuestras cabezas
una realidad muy diferente a la que se
vive en tiss Jordania
decenas de personas han sido víctimas
mortales de los bombardeos israelíes Y
son muchos los que han tenido que
enterrar a sus seres queridos entre
estos en niños
estamos destrozados por dentro Aunque
consigamos sobrevivir esta guerra
necesitamos tratamientos psiquiátrico
tras el dolor experimentado
en la región la liga árabe y otras
potencias han condenado los hechos pero
Israel no ha dado señales de contemplar
una tregua y advertido sobre una posible
escalada
mi instrucción es que estemos preparados
tanto para la posibilidad de una mayor
expansión de la campaña como para golpes
muy duros solo en lo que va de año ya ha
muerto más de 100 palestinos y una
decena de israelíes en estos
enfrentamientos